Speaker 1: Earlier, we looked at clips of
interviews that Luke Beasley did with Trump
supporters at his rally in Pickens, South
Carolina, over the holiday weekend.
Let's now look at clips of the actual rally.
One of the most interesting things was that
Republican South Carolina Senator Lindsey
Graham was brutally, brutally booed.
He had a speech himself and he was booed and
ran off stage.
And then when Trump talked about him, he was
also booed.
Here is Lindsey cutting it short after getting
heckled the entire time and running off of
the stage.
You really you love to see it.
You really do.
Speaker 5: God bless America.
Speaker 1: A visibly frustrated Lindsey Graham,
brutally booed by a supposedly friendly MAGA
crowd and walked off stage when Trump mentioned
Lindsey.
The crowd also not convinced.
Speaker 4: Twice now.
You know, you can make mistakes on occasion.
Even Lindsey down here, Senator Lindsey Graham.
Unidentified: We love said.
We're going to act.
We're going to love him.
Speaker 4: We're going to love him.
I know it's half and half, but what I need
some of those liberal votes.
He's always there to help me get right.
We've got some pretty liberal people, but
he's good.
He's good.
We know the good ones.
We know the bad.
Speaker 1: Crowd is very, very, very, very
much not convinced.
Trump then going into woke going into elements
of woke and says, nobody knows what Wokeness
is.
Speaker 4: Doing for women.
And, you know, the amazing thing because of
our crazy woke society and I hate the word
woke actually, because nobody even has a real
accurate description.
It means lack of common sense more than anything
else.
But because of.
Speaker 1: Sorry, sir, woke means you are
aware of injustices in society and you'd like
to fix them, at least if it's possible.
Trump, As news was breaking about his phone
call to pressure Arizona's governor to overturn
the 2020 election results, weighed in during
his speech about his phone call to try to
get Georgia officials to overturn the election
results.
And he continues to exist, insist, rather.
This was just a perfect call.
Speaker 4: Copy of it.
It was a perfect call.
These were perfect calls.
These were calls where you're questioning
the validity and the safety of elections.
And it's a disgrace that they're allowed to
even think about it.
But that one person protested until long after
that call.
Right.
And if there was something wrong with that
call, I am not a stupid person.
Number one, I'm an honest person, so I wouldn't
do it anyway.
But when people are right.
Speaker 1: Trump would know whether there
was anything right or wrong, whether there
was anything wrong with the call.
That's not true.
Trump doesn't know anything, and Trump would
never lie about the call.
That's not true.
Trump lies all the.
Speaker 4: Time, I think many lawyers.
Do you think many people were on that phone?
Many, many people.
Do you think I'm going to say what they'd
like to have?
But the problem is it's not borne out.
I will tell you what is borne out.
The call was supposedly taped in the state
of Florida.
And in Florida, you're not allowed to do,
you know, that's a two party state.
In other words, you're not allowed to take
phone calls.
They taped the phone call to show you how
nice they are.
They take the phone call.
Speaker 1: All right.
So Trump rambling and rambling about that.
None of us believe it.
And then lastly, Donald Trump directly attacking
special prosecutor Jack Smith.
It's hard to believe this is a good strategy.
Speaker 4: For the presidential record, Jack.
Well, that's what they should be looking at,
because everything I did was under the Presidential
Records Act, we have a thug prosecutor named
Smith, Jack Smith.
He's a thug.
He's had many losses.
He's destroyed many lives.
And they put him in charge In the meantime.
What about Biden's records?
This guy has 1850 boxes.
He has boxes stored in Chinatown in D.C.
Rough place, by the way.
Speaker 1: And Trump continuing to tell the
same debunked lies about Joe Biden and his
documents.
It's the greatest hits, but I have to tell
you, even the cult crowd seems a little bit
skeptical, but not the cultists we're about
to look at.
Video of